RUTH EDMONDS, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT WAS GREAT TO TALK TO YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: SO IT'S COMING
BACK, INDOOR MASK MANDATES IN
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CITIES IN THE
COUNTRY.
YOU SHOULD KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE.
TRACE GALLAGHER DOES AND HE'S
GOT THE STORY FOR US NOW.
>> IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A CASE
STUDY ON HOW TO GENERATE
CONFUSION, THE L.A. COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT JUST GAVE US A
STEP-BY-STEP GUIDE.
HERE'S THE REASON CORONAVIRUS
CASES IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY ARE
NOW ABOVE 1,000 FOR THE SEVENTH
STRAIGHT DAY, THEREFORE
EVERYONE, INCLUDING THOSE FULLY
VACCINATED, ONCE AGAIN HAVE TO
WEAR A MASK INDOORS.
FEDERAL GUIDANCE IS THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
CDC DIRECTOR ROCHELLE WALENSKY
SAYS VACCINATED PEOPLE ARE SAFE
FROM THE DELTA VARIANT OF THE
CORONAVIRUS AND DO NOT HAVE TO
WEAR MASKS INDOORS.
IN FACT, EVEN WHEN THE
L.A. COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT
WAS ISSUING THE MANDATE TODAY IT
WAS SIMULTANEOUSLY MAKING ITS
CASE AND UNDERMINING ITS CASE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE COUNTY SAYS
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE NOW AT 452.
THAT'S UP FROM LAST WEEK BUT THE
COUNTY GOES ON TO SAY, QUOTING
HERE, TO DATE WE HAVE NOT HAD A
PATIENT ADMITTED TO A HOSPITAL
WHO HAS BEEN FULLY VACCINATED
WITH EITHER D.J. AND JAY,
PFIZER, OR MENTOR
MATERNAL VACCINES.EVERY PATIENTE
ADMITTED FOR COVID IS NOT FULLY
VACCINATED.
IF THEY ARE NOT GETTING SICK,
WHY DO THEY HAVE TO WEAR A MASK.
BUSINESSES HAVE NO WAY OF
VERIFYING WHO HAS AND HAS NOT
BEEN VACCINATED SO IT IS NOT ONE
SIZE FITS ALL AND FINALLY THE
COUNTY DIRECTOR IS NOT RULING
OUT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
STRICTER MANDATES, INCLUDING
MORE SHUTDOWNS.
STAY TUNED, TUCKER.
L.A. COUNTY APPEARS TO BE ON A